dieser Planet hier aus interstellar hat
mich damals im Kino mega fasziniert eine
Stunde die hier auf der Oberfläche
vergeht bedeuten 7 Jahre auf der Erde
und dann auch noch diese riesigen Wellen
die die Crew bedrohen und das ist
überhaupt flüssiges Wasser gibt obwohl
der Planet um ein gigantisches schwarzes
lochkreist und nicht um einen Stern der
Ausflug auf millas Planeten ist eine der
spannendsten und wissenschaftlich
faszinierendsten Szenen von interstellar
ihr habt uns gefragt ob es einen solchen
Planeten überhaupt geben könnte und
genau diese Frage wollen wir jetzt
beantworten
[Musik]
interstellar ist dafür bekannt
wissenschaftlich besonders akkurat zu
sein das liegt vor allem an Christopher
Nolans hochkarätigen Berater dem
Physiker und Nobelpreisträger kippform
seine Aufgabe war es ein möglichst
realistisches Szenario für die Story von
interstellar zu entwerfen und kippt
voran ging mit so viel Sorgfalt an die
Sache heran dass er sogar
zweifachartikel über die nie da
gewesenen Simulationen eines Wurmlochs
und eines Schwarzen Lochs
veröffentlichen konnte die Vorgaben für
millas Planeten er sollte potentiell
bewohnbar sein im Stundentakt sollten
gigantische Wellen über den Planeten
schwappen aber vor allem sollte die Zeit
auch mit das Planeten 60.000 mal
langsamer vergehen als auf der Erde und
Achtung Spoiler alle drei Dinge könnten
tatsächlich in unserem Universum
existieren aber dafür müssten sowohl der
Planet als auch das schwarze Loch und
dass er kreist ganz besondere
Eigenschaften haben
[Musik]
Milas Planet ist deshalb ein
Missionsziel weil er potenziell
bewohnbar sein könnte der felsig-planet
ist der etwa erdgross seine Schwerkraft
ist nur 30% größer als die der Erde
außerdem gibt es dort flüssiges Wasser
sogar sehr viel davon Wasser ist keine
Seltenheit im Universum aber meistens
liegt es entweder als Eis oder als Gas
vor selten flüssig nun kreist millas
Planet aber nicht um einen Stern sondern
um ein schwarzes Loch das Licht
verschluckt sollte es da nicht auch eher
kalt und dunkel sein nun dem ist
tatsächlich nicht so denn millas Planet
befindet sich zwischen dem Schwarzen
Loch und seiner aggressionsscheibe das
ist eine heiße Scheibe aus Materie die
sich um das schwarze Loch ansammelt in
etwa so wie die Ringe des Saturn
Magnetfelder in dieser
aggressionsscheibe bewirken dass ich
Gravitationsenergie in Wärme und dann
auch Licht umwandelt Aggression Scheiben
von Schwarzen Löchern können so gerne
mal 100 Millionen Grad heiß werden und
jetzt von massiver Strahlung ausstoßen
das ist also nicht dass es zu kalt sein
könnte sondern tatsächlich eher zu heiß
deshalb hat kipfhorn garantuar gezähmt
so wird das schwarze Loch von Millers
Planeten genannt und seine
aggressionsscheibe wird nur ein paar
tausend Grad heiß wenn etwa so viel wie
die Oberfläche der Sonne denn garantua
hat in den letzten 10 Millionen Jahren
keinen Stern mehr gefrühstückt das hat
vorhin so bestimmt und das ist auch gut
so denn die Kuh muss ja auf dem Planeten
herumlaufen können ohne gebraten zu
werden
millas Planet ist also warm genug das
Wasser nicht gefriert aber auch nicht so
heiß dass Menschen dort zugrunde gehen
und schließlich ist die Schwerkraft auf
Planet groß genug um eine Atmosphäre zu
besitzen deren Druck das Wasser in
flüssigem Zustand hält und es nicht
direkt verdampfen lässt
die Schwerkraft die die Kuh auf Villas
Planet erlebt hat übrigens nichts mit
dem schwarzen Loch zu tun sondern nur
mit seiner eigenen Masse wenn man auf
der Oberfläche des Planeten steht
erfährt man also nur die 1,3 g
Schwerkraft vom Planeten selber das
schwarze Loch macht die Crew nicht
schwerer aber die Gezeitenkräfte die
fast stündlich einen gigantischen
Tsunami erzeugen sind durchaus Garant du
hast schuld
[Musik]
Ebbe und Flut entstehen auf der Erde
weil der Mond mit seiner Schwerkraft an
ihr zieht für die Erde bedeutet das dass
sie entlang einer Achse gestreckt und in
der Senkrechten dazu zusammengedrückt
wird da wo sich Mond und Erde am
nächsten sind und auf der
gegenüberliegenden Seite entsteht darum
jeweils eine Art Wasserberg unter dem
sich die Erde weiter dreht so erleben
wir hoch und tiefwasserphasen also die
Zeiten die Gezeitenkräfte auf millas
Planet sollten aber extrem sein deshalb
hat kipforen die größere Garant was auf
100 Millionen Sonnenmassen festgelegt
wäre das schwarze Loch noch größer
würden sich die Kräfte die an
verschiedenen Stellen auf Millers
Planeten wirken nicht genug
unterscheiden um gigantische Fluten zu
erzeugen wäre es kleiner während die
Kräfte so unterschiedlich dass sie den
Planeten zerreißen würden so ist der
Planet zwar insgesamt in eine ovale Form
gestreckt aber bleibt in einem Stück
mit Gezeitenkräften am zerreißpunkt
ergibt sich aber ein neues Problem würde
millas Planet sich so drehen wie die
Erde dann würde er dem Schwarzen Loch
ständig eine andere Seite zuwenden der
Planet würde dann bei jeder Umrundung so
massiv durchgeknetet dass er zum Magma
Ball werden würde das ging natürlich von
der Story her nicht deshalb dreht sich
millas Planet mit jeder Umrundung fast
genau einmal um die eigene Achse so dass
immer die gleiche Seite zum Schwarzen
Loch zugewandt bleibt aber die
Ausrichtung ist nicht perfekt Milas
Planet wechselt im Stundentakt zwischen
zwei Orientierungen hin und her so
entstehen die gigantischen Tsunamis die
bei jeder Umkehr über die Oberfläche des
Planeten jagen der Grund warum Millers
Planet so großen Gezeitenkräften
ausgesetzt ist ist sein extrem niedriger
Orbit und der muss so niedrig sein damit
die Zeit die latation funktioniert und
das ist wahrscheinlich der Grund warum
ihr auf dieses Video hier geklickt habt
aber bevor es soweit ist wollte ich euch
noch etwas über erzählen unsere letzten
Videos gesehen hat der kennt über
vielleicht schon das ist ein flexibler
Stromanbieter bei dem ihr euren
Stromverbrauch quasi in Echtzeit
einsehen und vom Markt beziehen könnt
das bedeutet ihr habt die Möglichkeit
den Strom zum Börsenpreis einzukaufen
und eben dann zu nutzen wenn er gerade
günstig ist das ist vor allem bei
größeren Geräten sinnvoll wie der
Waschmaschine den Trockner oder dem
E-Auto wenn ihr eins habt und wenn ihr
das regelmäßig macht kann aber schon ein
relevanter Betrag eingespart werden was
natürlich gerade jetzt super wichtig ist
außerdem tut ihr auch der Umwelt etwas
Gutes denn wenn Strom gerade günstig ist
ist der in der Regel auch besonders grün
am Ende zahlt ihr also neben dem
üblichen Steuern und Gebühren nur das
was der Strom gerade am Markt kostet
plus eine monatliche Servicegebühr von
3,99 € Gewinn macht sie aber durch den
Stromverkauf nicht um euren digitalen
Stromzähler für eine genaue Abrechnung
fit zu machen benötigt ihr dann noch den
stromtrackers von Twitter den könnt ihr
euch ganz einfach auf euren Stromzähler
draufsetzen und eure Verbrauchsdaten
werden verschlüsselt an die App gesendet
damit sie dann in Echtzeit was ihr
gerade an Strom verbraucht
den Parts könnt ihr euch übrigens zum
halben Preis sichern wenn ihr bei der
Anmeldung den Code Watson eingebt dann
bekommt ihr nämlich nach
Vertragsabschluss einen Gutschein über
50 € für den tipperstore und ganz
nebenbei unterstützt sie damit auch noch
uns und unsere Videos hier vielen Dank
dafür also der wechselt dauert nur 5
Minuten ist gerade jetzt wahrscheinlich
super sinnvoll und in der App findet ihr
auch Infos zum effektiven Stromsparen
und falls es euch dann doch nicht
gefallen sollte könnt ihr innerhalb von
zwei Wochen einfach wieder kündigen
ein schwarzes Loch hat so viel Masse das
ist die Raumzeit extrem krümmt solche
Effekte können wir im Kleinen auch hier
bei uns beobachten so ist die Strecke
die ein Funksignal überbrücken muss und
50 km länger wenn es dicht an der Sonne
vorbei muss weil die Sonne den Raum den
dient und die Gravitation der Erde
reicht um die Zeit auf der Erde 40
Mikrosekunden pro Tag langsamer vergehen
zu lassen als in 20.000 km Höhe bei
einem schwarzen Loch können wir solche
Effekte im extremen sehen dabei
beobachten wir die größten Effekte nahe
dem Ereignishorizont denn der Ereignis
Horizont ist die Distanz zum Schwarzen
Loch an der die Gravitation so groß wird
dass selbst Licht ins Schwarze Loch
hineinfällt innerhalb des
ereignishorizonts sind die Raumzeit
Effekte natürlich noch größer aber
beobachten können wir sie leider nicht
bei gagantur ist der Radius des Ereignis
Horizonts etwa 150 Millionen Kilometer
groß das entspricht genau der Entfernung
zwischen Erde und Sonne damit millas
Planet die gewünschte 60.000-fache Zeit
Dehnung erlebt muss ein Orbit also
möglichst nahe am Ereignishorizont dran
sein und um das zu erreichen muss ich
garantuar extrem schnell um sich selbst
drehen das leuchtet nicht sofort ein ist
mir klar deswegen lass mich das mal kurz
erklären damit millas Planet einen
stabilen Orbit so nah am
Ereignishorizont finden kann muss die
extreme Schwerkraft von einer extremen
Fliehkraft aufgehoben werden und die
können wir nur erreichen wenn sich
millas Planet extrem schnell bewegt wie
beschleunigen wir also den Planeten wenn
ein schwarzes Loch rotiert entsteht ein
raumzeitwirbel der wiederum Materie
mitreißt wenn also der Spin die
Rotationsgeschwindigkeit des Schwarzen
Lochs hoch genug ist beschleunigt das
auch unseren Planeten
wie schnell muss garantuar rotieren nur
extrem schnell also selbst für ein
schwarzes Loch extrem schnell der
maximal mögliche Spin eine Schwarzen
Lochs ist erreicht wenn die mitgerissene
Materie am Ereignishorizont auf
Lichtgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt wurde
kippform hat berechnet dass bei 99,8 %
dieser theoretischen
Maximalgeschwindigkeit bremseneffekte so
stark werden dass es unwahrscheinlich
wird dass ein schwarzes Loch sich noch
schneller dreht Beobachtungen zeigen
auch häufig deutlich langsameresspins
aber selbst die 99,8% reichen uns nicht
da Gant Tour ist deshalb eine Ausnahme
sein Spin kommt bis auf ein trillionstel
an die Maximalgeschwindigkeit heran und
das beschleunigt auch Millers Planeten
extrem eher umrunde in 1,7 Stunden auf
einem Orbit gerade weit genug Horizont
entfernt um nicht hinein zu fallen
ist quasi ein Basketball auf dem Ring er
liegt dabei die gleiche Strecke zurück
wie die Erde beim Umkreisen der Sonne
und eine Milliarde Kilometer damit
bewegt sich millas Planet fast mit
halber Lichtgeschwindigkeit und genau
das sorgt dann auch für die extreme
zeitdelatration die Gravitation von
garantuar der niedrige Orbit und die
Geschwindigkeit von Millers Planet
mussten alle so gewählt werden damit die
unglaubliche Zeit Dilatation möglich
wird nur so können auf der Erde 7 Jahre
vergehen während auf Millers Planet nur
eine Stunde vergeht danke Einstein
kippform konstruierte mit Millers
Planeten eine faszinierende Welt nach
den Vorgaben der Geschichte die
Christopher Nolan erzählen wollte und
das krasse ist dabei blieb er fest im
Bereich des physikalisch vorstellbaren
wenn das schwarze Loch also fast mit der
Maximalgeschwindigkeit rotiert der
Planet sich exakt in der richtigen
Geschwindigkeit um sich selbst dreht und
einen Orbit gefährlich nah am
Ereignishorizont hat dann ist Millers
Planet also absolut nicht unmöglich aber
doch eher unwahrscheinlich auf der
anderen Seite im interstellar spielen
Raum und Zeit für die Menschen der
Zukunft keine Rolle mehr und wenn man in
einem gigantischen Universum lange genug
wartet dann tritt auch das
unwahrscheinlichste Phänomen irgendwann
einmal ein also wie immer bleibt
neugierig